hey 42 here Crime and Punishment
they go together like pen and paper like
summer and barbecues and like bacon and
well bacon goes with everything but
sometimes you get crime without
punishment and society feels like it's
being hard done by we all love a good
bit of justice and there's nothing quite
like a great detective unraveling a
criminals evil scheme although it's not
always possible a vital clue might be
missing witnesses disappear bloody
fingerprint turns out to be ketchup from
a hungry detectives lunch so let's get
together Sherlock Holmes Poirot Columbo
and that guy from CSI Miami who's always
taking his sunglasses off and
investigate some of the world's greatest
unsolved two crimes
Elizabeth Short was a lot shorter when
they found her since somebody had cut
her right in half she remains one of Los
Angeles longest unsolved cases and the
Black Dahlia as she is commonly known
inspired many a good book movie and TV
show through the years the nickname is
likely linked to the 1946 film the blue
dolly a crime thriller written by one of
the greatest detective novelists of all
time
Raymond Chan Elizabeth had a difficult
life before her death she grew up in
Massachusetts and when she was just six
years old her father's car was found
parked on a bridge and it was assumed
that he had committed suicide after
losing everything in the 1929 stock
market crash but a letter arrived in
California years later with her father
apologizing and telling her he lived in
California he couldn't find that sorry I
faked my death and ran away apology card
at the gas station Elizabeth eventually
moved to join her father in California
and they left together in LA for a while
but she moved towns after they had an
argument and she flitted around various
California locations until she was found
dead in Leimert Park
right I guess you want the grisly
details now don't you maybe he should
load up a video some puppies you know as
a backup so when Betty burger and her
three-year-old daughter found Elizabeth
Short on 15th of January in 1947 they
thought she was actually a shop
mannequin since the top and bottom
halves of her were over a foot apart and
she was posed with her hands and both
her head she had whole pieces of flesh
removed and was largely drained of blood
some of which was found in a cement sack
nearby she also had a Glasgow smile
where the corners of her mouth were
sliced up to her ears there have been
many suspects over the years including
Walter Bailey a surgeon Norman Chandler
publisher of the Los Angeles Times mark
Hanson a Hollywood nightclub owner and
the most compelling suspect dr. George
Hill Hoda you can see why they made
movies out of this story Conte there are
so many rumors about the Black Dahlia
such as her being a sex worker and even
the opposite that she was unable to have
sex due to a birth defect but none of
these have ever been substantiated and
the mystery is still unsolved our next
pair of murders involves a whole lot of
beef but it's okay vegetarians no cows
were harmed just two of the world's
greatest rappers Biggie and Tupac in
1994 2pac survives a shooting outside
New York's quad studios and he managed
to get into an elevator and get back
upstairs to where Biggie and some of his
crew the 2pac and biggie were friends at
this point but 2pac accused Biggie of
knowing that the shooting was going to
take place
biggie denied it but soon after released
the song who shot you
and although probably just a taunt 2pac
really took it to heart things escalated
quickly into a full East Coast West
Coast rivalry rap beefs are pretty
common and they give the industry a lot
of entertainment value often becoming a
sort of x-rated soap opera but whereas
these days it probably just ends up with
Azealia Banks being banned from Twitter
2pac and biggie had a much more
final ending when both we're guns down
six months apart in 96 and 97 no killer
has been brought to justice for even
murder there were just rumors of various
gangsters and even the FBI being
responsible let's have a break from
murder shall we no one died it's a crime
but it could be said that it actually
represented a far more dangerous threat
in anything else on this list on
Christmas Eve 2000 a hacker named Li
accessed a navy computer in Washington
and stole most of the source code for
exigent ôs comet software which is used
to guide satellites and missiles some
geeks have a very weird idea of what
makes a good present just what is wrong
with reindeer print socks
the FBI's Chris Murray played down the
importance of that saying it wasn't an
intelligence disaster since the data was
unclassified but it's still pretty
worrying that you could potentially have
some 13 year old kids sitting on
classified military information although
to be fair we did let George W Bush have
the nuke codes and he choked on a
pretzel least identity has never been
discovered the hack was traced back to
the University of Kaiserslautern in
Germany but then the trail went dead
this is not the only time an unknown
hacker has messed with the US government
in 1989 a digital worm was created
called wagging which stood for worms
against nuclear killers it's infected
NASA computers and cost half a million
dollars of time and resources to fix
computers infected with the virus were
beautifully presented with a message on
screen that said your computer has been
officially wiped it's rumored that one
of the hackers could have been WikiLeaks
founder Julian Assange a heist now one
of the biggest unsolved hauls in history
On February 2 2015 and five men
disguised in klm uniforms duster major
Dutch airline tricked their way out onto
the tarmac of Amsterdam's Airport
Schiphol they had a stolen KLM cargo
vehicle and they managed to stop an
armored truck which was transporting on
diamonds they took the diamonds at
gunpoint although no shots were fired
and then they made off the truck was
found abandoned but the identities of
the robbers remains mystery it's hard to
estimate how much their haul would work
since the diamonds were uncut and the
cutting determines a lot of their value
but it's fought to have been well over a
hundred million dollars so not too bad
for an afternoon work it's been noted
that this heist bears a lot of
similarities to the 2013 one in Antwerp
where men in security uniforms driving
the vehicles of Belgian security forces
raced out onto the runway
and took 120 boxes full of diamonds that
were being loaded onto a plane bound for
Zurich in both cases no guns were fired
they knew the exact time and location of
the diamonds and the diamonds were uncut
which also makes them harder to track
this one was only a halt of a meagre 50
million dollars oaks hardly seems worth
the bother doesn't it if there is one
man you don't want to mess with its
Vladimir Putin he runs one of the
world's most powerful countries and he
rides on a horse without his shirt on
he's the manliest of men but Alexander
Litvinenko decided it would be a good
idea to poke the angry bear and rather
than ripping him in half the Great Bear
knocked him off with a sneaky bit of
radioactive poisoning this is all
conjecture of course Alexander
Litvinenko was a former Russian FSB
officer who ended up living in London
the Russian FSB are the successors of
the infamous KGB he left Russia on the
controversial circumstances having been
investigated when he publicly accused
his superiors of ordering the
assassination Russian tycoon Boris
Berezovsky Berezovsky had been a friend
of Putin's from the early 90s but their
relationship deteriorated soon after
Putin left his position as head of the
FSB and became president in 2011 Yenko
was acquitted twice in 99 and 2000 and
subsequently fled to money where he
worked with British intelligence and
wrote two books accusing the FSB
some shady behavior which helped buting
claim power on the 1st of november 2006
he fell ill and was hospitalized quickly
diagnosed is being poisoned by
radioactive polonium-210 which is one of
the most toxic substances known to
mankind
obviously access to the substance is
strictly controlled and there's also the
small facts that's you need access to a
nuclear reactor
- absolutely obtain it so if you happen
to be at a business meeting with two
other Russians and drink tea containing
a lethal dose of polonium 210 just like
Litvinenko did then it's probably not an
accident he died on the 23rd November a
British investigation pointed to Andrey
Lugovoy a Russian government agent but
nothing could be proven since Russia
refused to extradite him so the case
remains open the only thing we know for
sure is if a Russian man offers you a
glowing sandwich politely tell him
you're not hungry ok let's play a quick
game of odd one which one of these
sounds like something you shouldn't find
at the beach
craps sand seagulls disembodied human
feet ice cream
if you said ice cream then you had a
very depressing childhood along the
coast of the Salish Sea in British
Columbia Canada some 20 human feet have
been found on the shore in the past 10
years almost all have been ranked feet
also almost all of the washed up feet
were wearing running shoes what's
happening now a serial killer 4c sharks
a really strong ankle high-current well
a body can remain in the water for up to
three decades and feet can easily become
detached for natural decomposition so
the feet could have just washed up from
bodies of people who had drowned at sick
but why British Columbia specifically
nowhere else in the world have feet
washed up on beaches in one location
with such frequency it does British
Columbia have it's very own Dexter style
murderer on the loose one of the biggest
problems in identifying the source of
the lost limbs
is that the feet themselves become
difficult to analyze since they produce
a lot of Erebus here
and a perceivers known as corpse wax and
it's an organic substance produced by
bacteria during the decomposition of
body fat it causes difficulties in
forensics because it's very temperature
dependent so unless you know the exact
environments the body was in during
decomposition
it makes age estimation very difficult
some of the feet are from people
believed you have committed suicide
there is also a case of a missing
fisherman in the area it's been
suggested that some of them could have
come from the 2004 Asian tsunami which
would match some of the running shoes
production locations and the direction
of the currents or perhaps it's all the
work of one serial killer who has a
grave dislike for those blasted runners
who keep treading up his front yard
every morning he did warn them there's a
surprisingly large crime industry around
our next topic after drugs money
laundering and arms dealing it's one of
the biggest illegal businesses in the
game what do you think it is
carjacking armed robbery really awful
parking it's actually the romantic world
of art theft which clocks in at about 6
billion dollars annually and the
greatest art heist of all time was from
the Isabella Stewart Gardner Museum in
Boston USA in the early hours of the
18th of March 1992 men dressed as local
police arrived at the Museum and told
the security they'd been called for a
disturbance in the yard they then
proceeded to truss up the guards and
walked off with an incredible collection
of work for master painters such as
Degas Rembrandt and Malick it's hard to
put a price on it what some say was
almost half a billion dollars of classic
art there were no real leads and none of
the Arts has resurfaced the museum
director and Hawley saw the bigger
picture and went as far as to publicly
release details for the fees as to how
best to store the paintings thinking
it's better that they at least survive
intact even if they are hanging in some
shady billionaire pool it seems like
it's surprisingly easy to pick up a
Picasso or steal a Sheila in 2010 a loan
thief just broke a window in
Pavlov and that's all it took to get
into the Paris Museum of Modern Art and
dance off with a Matisse and a Picasso
among governor's not exactly what I
would call state-of-the-art security but
rather than cashing in on his millions
one of his accomplices claims that
whilst he was being questioned by the
police that he had just thrown the
paintings into a rubbish truck
rather than paint himself into a corner
and have a nasty brush with the law
we're staying with art for our last
crime though but rather than stealing it
the creation is the crime it's the
world's favorite graffiti artist the
mysterious Banksy he's a British artist
that grew out of the underground scene
in Bristol and his work often highly
political in nature has appeared
everywhere from London
to Disneyland to the Gaza Strip pieces
of his work have sold for over 1 million
dollars and he's even made an
oscar-nominated documentary called exit
through the kitchen but he or she or
them has never revealed that true
identity perhaps to enjoy the anonymity
but probably due to the illegality of
his work it's not just graffiti since
he's also done things like produce fake
British banknotes with Princess Diana
replacing the Queen and Banksy of
England written on them he's also
mastered Paris Hilton's album launched
in 2006 by switching out her CDs and
replacing them with his own remixed
versions including tracks like why am i
famous what have I done and what am i
for a UK newspaper The Mail on Sunday
claims to have proven that Banksy is
actually a man called Robin gunning CIM
using Geographic profiling to match his
locations with his activities and
protests normally reserved for serious
crimes and tracking viral outbreaks
so maybe the writing is on the wall for
his anonymity but until he's caught
red-handed the mystery of this
world-famous criminal slush artist will
remain I'd like to thank Squarespace for
supporting me on this video which helps
me to make better content do you want to
make a super slick site without knowing
all the technical jargon
well Squarespace makes it super easy
with
intuitive tools you can make
professionally designed size super quick
regardless of your experience and you
don't need to write a single line of
code they'll even give you a free domain
name if you sign up for a year click the
link in description to start your free
trial today at squarespace.com forward
slash 40 make sure you use the offer
code 44 10% of your first purchase
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2 just outside of munich lies a
sleepy village called fugu right where
the rent for a whole year is just under
1 euro meet the most audacious
granddad's this side of a Sunday roast
the so called
grandpa gang pulled off the largest
burglary in English history